that says what is the harm in
supporting a political party
or candidate or maybe they're asking is there
harm in supporting a political party or candidate
let me pray again father in heaven be with
me as i deal with this very sensitive issue
and all the remaining questions in jesus
name i pray amen so they don't say uh
they didn't elaborate if this
is their their personal opinion
that's all right that's okay now the church
has no political stance as far as i know
jesus told pilate my kingdom is not of this
world it's just not we know from daniel 2 21
he removeth kings and setteth up kings we
know from jeremiah 27 verse 6 and all these
lands have i given into the hand of the king of
nebuchadnezzar the king of babylon my servant
and all the beasts have i given to him also to
serve him and all nations shall serve him and
his sons and his son now until the very time of
his kingdom come or his land come in other words
when his time is up someone else will take over
god has overall control now nebuchadnezzar was
a very cruel man but god put him in power and god
said i have given him when you decide to support
someone it's your right to do that you become in
some degree responsible for the person's behavior
let me say it again in some degree you
are responsible for what the person does
let's say you voted for hitler or idi amin or
paul pot or stalin in some degree you contributed
now let's say the person turns out to be
a saint and you didn't me perhaps you did
not support someone could be a blessing
to society it's a very personal choice
but the church must be very very careful that
they do not go from involvement to absorption
i need to explain that you can become involved
without being absorbed you go to the beach to
take a swim you're in the ocean you're not a fish
if you feel convicted to support one or the other
by the spirit of god having prayed and
used the promise of psalm 32 verse 8
i will instruct thee and teach this psalm 25 4
show me thy ways of god then i can condemn you
but remember the earthly system is not god's
system the last time god had a kingdom on earth
was when zedekiah was king he was captured by
the babylonians god no longer had a kingdom on
the earth that's why jesus could say my kingdom is
not of this world if my kingdom were of this world
then would my servants fight you understand
that i should not be delivered unto you
and so political questions cause tremendous
damage in the church it splits churches it
breaks up relationship and the prayer of christ
in john 17 that they all may be one that they all
may be one that they all may be one we must avoid
whatever will ruin the unity of the church if the
unity is based on truth if politics will divide
the church we ought to avoid whatever if risk
divides the church if whatever devised we must
place the church above every other consideration
because the prayer of christ was that we
should be one and let me tell you something
there's a literal verse in uh philippians
3 20 for our conversation is in heaven
from whence also if we look for the savior the
lord jesus who shall change our vile bodies
that it may be fashioned like after his glorious
body the word conversation means citizenship this
is not symbolic a genuine christian his or her
first level of citizenship is heaven that's why
when the sunday law is passed first in this
country a genuine believer will not obey it
because that person obeys the commandment of god's
kingdom that's where his or her citizenship is it
is not symbolic you must understand if you truly
accept christ your citizenship is first as a child
of god's kingdom everything else comes second
so i can't tell you whether or not you should
follow a party or not all i'm telling you is
politics divide not only churches it divides
families it divides communities it has citizens
killing each other and fighting each other
that sort of thing should be kept out of the
church but you make your personal choice but
as far as i know the church does not come out and
support this party when ben carson ran the church
made it clear they're not supporting one party
over another that's not the work of the church
amen let me say something else about the church
the church is not a social service agency
let me explain the church let me be most
precise and narrow and politically incorrect
the seventh-day adventist church god's remnant
people were not raised up to give off bread and
clothes and shoes now it does that that's not why
it was raised because many other organizations do
the same thing are you following me this church
was raised to do a work no other organization does
or can do which is the proclamation of the three
angels messages plus the message of revelation 18
1-5 there is no other organization and while we
engage in social actions and relieving the poor
nothing must distract us from the purpose for
which we are raised up people make very clever
arguments i will not attend the church it doesn't
feed the poor it doesn't uh clothe the naked i
understand that the church does that but saying
the church does that is different from saying
that's the reason why the church exists that
is not the reason why the church exists the
church exists to proclaim a message that will
prepare the world to receive jesus christ
and only the remnant people of god can do that yes
we give food we have clothes we build houses we
do all of that that is simply what we do in the
pursuit of our central mission the proclamation
of a message that will bring christ back to a
world that's ready for him ready for him as a
friend ready for him as an enemy as revelation 14
has two harvests right for god ripe against god
it is the message of revelation 14 that brings
the world to that condition and the world is
not brought to that condition just by feeding the
poor or giving shoes to people who have no shoes
as good as that is and i'm no i'm sure that people
misunderstanding that is good but that's not why
the church was raised remember in luke chapter
12 this young man said master lord speak to
my brother that he divide the inheritance with
me jesus says man who made me a judge over you
i'm not here for that but what was so wrong in
setting a dispute nothing but i didn't come for
that when john the baptist was put in prison
he was the cousin of jesus jesus left the area
that was not his work it may look cold we need to
understand why am i a part of the adventist church
and people who have no sense of purpose can easily
mislead in all kinds of directions jesus left he
didn't go get him out didn't go visit him not
because he is called that was not his mission
next question let's keep our focus right um as as
christians as as remnant we keep keep our focus
we have to keep our focus on
satan will give us a focus
you